This
[Music]
Your mysterious powers revealed when you came to the island, your
talent, your affinity for water fur,
if you were the embodiment of the water dragon, it would all make sense
[Music] I wo
n't let you confirm it.
[Music] Will you
put your hands together?
[Music]
[Applause] There is
no doubt that there is a deep flow that lives deep within each individual's life. It is the
incarnation of the water dragon that Makoto Yanagi adopted from within his veins and raised as his own child.  That's
you, but it
seems like you're still just a baby dragon.You're the
embodiment of great power, but at the same time you're still only a 15-
year-old boy.You'll be the one who
restores your true nature and brings harmony back to this island.
Is this the end of his long training, or does he
need a new ritual? There is no
time right now to unravel the mystery left behind by his master.
Yukito-kun, what I wish for you now is to be the eldest
brother of Ichifumi Yanagi, and the younger
brother of the staff.  It's just a normal thing to hope. I want you to
live your days in good health,
continue practicing in your daily life, and someday
become the true you that you should be.
[Music]
Maybe you can face the
truth within yourself now.
Kai: Excuse me. Well
then, it's farewell. Yukito,
Chataro,
Yacomoko and you, you and Momoko, please evacuate to the mainland.
Either way, Sensei will go to the
island of 4 and do the same thing as Master, and
then neither I nor I will accompany you. That's
how I feel.  I'll just take it. I
'll leave the three of you to humanity. It's a bit of a
problem, but
don't fight. We're all a
family learning the same school.
[Music]